Today's topic. This guy calls himself, poppy, Don. There's two things. A woman.
Want to hear her cash app Ze, and what's her full name and birthday book.
Her trip. If you really want her do something different,
I'm asking her to the movies at the dinner. She can drive there herself.
Do something. No one else is asking her for, take her on vacation. You cheap,
broke bastards. All. Otherwise, leave her alone.
Let a rich demon come and get her. Oh man,
she need to be nobody wanna hear about your spiritual future mother.
She wanna be on a plane, getting back shots on a balcony.
The first day you meet her, treat her.
She already went on a date with you. Now give her some money.
Then you wanna wonder why you don't get no pu at the end of the first or the
second date, you didn't let this girl get a head nails done,
pick out a outfit and drive to you,
offer some free dinner and a freaking conversation.
And you think that you go ahead at the end of the night. <laugh> listen.
If he don't do nothing for you on the first date, I,
I swear to God when you get back in the car, just text,
Shas just gotta text Shas these don't know what they doing out here.
Real. What are we watching? Well, I mean,
now that Derrick Jackson's left the scene, somebody's gotta take his place.
<Laugh> you tell men to take care of women and they write all these paragraphs,
make these videos, these don't deserve it. All they do is back this type of,
a sense these women is ho.
But if I made a video talking about how you could take care of your homeboy,
your day one, all your men around you, you be like, yeah, here's a real one.
If you gay just say that. Ma G when did they come?
A crime to take care of women, but you'll take care of your homeboy.
That's going to your girl anyway. <laugh>.
Okay. You got another one.
She don't want to hear you get money stories.
She doesn't want to hear about what clubs you've been. You traveled.
She's looking you dead in your eyes at your neck and your wrist.
And she's wondering why she ain't got one Zelle from you,
but you over here telling her about all this get money,
you wore your jewelry picked up in your nice car and she's still trying to
figure out why you ain't sending no money.
But all you keep talking about is money.
Tell me how these ladies sign.
I'm like my African siblings wondering when I'm gonna send them Western union
money. That's crazy. Tell me how, how we both live in a first.
I understand that they live where they live and they got their financial,
but you in the same country as me. Cause you live down the street,
but I gotta send you some Ze. Ask you that. What? For money? Yeah.
Oh yeah. Yeah. American woman have asked me for money.
Strip American woman have asked you for money a hundred percent. Why?
What do you mean? Why?
You've never heard of tricking? You've never heard of ladies who want favors.
Oh no. I come to think of it.
Some have asked me for money. Yeah. Yeah. They're comfortable.
They're very comfortable. Yeah. There's a lot of people who, who expect money.
That's a why. It's funny.
Cuz when I did the other video talking about like these women who want high v
alue dudes, a lot of women came up and said, well, we don't really want that.
It's not that common. Oh no. It's very common. It is common. It's.
Very common. And I, I don't like, I don't mind giving money if I don't know,
you don't ask for it. You know my family, not my friends, whatever.
I'm not gonna, it's not even money sometime. It's just, I go out,
I go out and people are gonna be like, yo, why you gonna buy me a drink?
Who are.
You for? For me? It's just, it's just the entitlement.
It's like y'all can get out here and say this kind of crazy stuff.
And people don't go out of their way to check you on it.
You know what I'm saying? Y'all can get on TV.
Y'all can pull a Cardi B y'all can be out here robbing dudes while they passed
out on Quaaludes. You could do whatever you want. And anything, a woman is,
is perfect. It it's fine. It's empowerment. It's whatever it is.
You know what I'm saying? And I'm just like, no, you trick it. And it's okay,
but let's call it what it is. And let's not promote it.
And this guy is simp. He's brown nosing. It's a.
Different form. I call it aggressive simp.
So you don't see it like that because he look like he's just the top of weight.
That is not like your normal he's at the end of the day. At the end of the day.
He's nosing. He is noses.
I'm not even gonna say he's cause I now hate that term and I believe it's
overused. I'm.
Use ease a, a who uses the word trash. Uh, no.
He's a massive enabler. Mm-hmm <affirmative>.
Yeah, yeah. Enabler. Yeah, that word is trash. That's what I'm gonna say.
A, I just wanted you to say Brad it's.
Thursday. Everybody's gonna DM her. Everybody wants to take her to dinner.
Take that girl shopping,
take $800 out your account and take that girl shopping.
You gonna do the same everybody else do. And get left on red,
leaving emojis and her DM. Take her shopping, do something different.
Buy her to clothes this week and she gonna wear. So when she's drunk,
she thinks about you and guess who's how she's going to, but what do I know?
Hey, have a good day.
And look at the top comment. I need more than 800 <laugh>.
But I gotta do one thing. What,
what you gotta do is do something other than what everybody else is
doing, going DM know, unless you're really attractive.
And you're really that, you know that nine to 10 or whatever.
Don't go a DM sending your like heart eyes and like that. Don't do that.
Do something special, do something different,
but you don't have to like spend hundred on her. Look.
Look at these comments. Look at these comments. So creepy,
but they don't even have the $800.
And then this one goes so glad I stumbled on this feed. Take him in school.
8 25. I want them to eat while we shop.
These gals are delusional. I can work with $800.
You got a mop on your head. is you talking about why you hated?
It's just the entitlement, bro. If I saw an ugly out, you're talking about,
he's gonna get some knives and some tents and he gonna bag you like, you know,
Naomi OSA. I'm like bro, you know, take your self,
take yourself and get some Naomi Walmart. Okay? Cause that's all you going.
Find, stop playing with me. And it's just, it's just.
Entitle. Don't don't get you a Naomi OSA. When you,
you deserve a Naomi Brampton <laugh>
and Naomi far Rockaway and Naomi Melo.
It's crazy, bro. Sometimes I feel like I'm in the Twilight.
Like who raised y'all but that's why I say like y'all they moved different.
Look ladies.
Ladies, ladies, if a man is on Instagram, talking about women,
don't deserve this blah. Say hello, Papa. Show me your baby mamas.
Show me your ex and watch 'em start stuttering.
That's where you'll learn is insecurities. It's either.
He lost him bad or the type of women you.
That's letting you for nothing. <laugh> nobody wants some bozo. <laugh>.
I don't see why you hate it from outside the club. You can get it. <laugh>.
Yeah. That's a lot. You did it. Do it again.
I dunno why you,
you need to put that. I don't. I dunno why you hate from outside the club.
You can't even get in <laugh> that's that laugh? That's the laugh.
You did. No Americans live for money, man. They moved different.
Oh. And you know,
with him advocated for this guarantee,
you he's not paying for the ladies who are now sliding into his bar.
Normal. You don't need to. No, you don't need to. You don't.
He don't need to be like that $800.
You gonna get it and then hit it and then ghosts, ghost.
Ghosts. Yeah. Don't get me wrong.
There's actually guys out there who enjoy pain, who enjoy that process.
And that's the thing. They don't wanna do the whole chit chat.
They don't wanna have organic stuff. That's fine. And that's fine.
But not ladies. A lot of them are just expecting that stuff.
They're just expecting it. I.
Respect the exchange of services and service. It's a service for money.
I get that. That's what business, natural business. You do,
whatever you gotta do. There's people that are willing to pay.
You do whatever you gotta do. There's some, people's like, no, you show up to,
I show up to a club and you be like, yo, pay me a drink for what?
I'm not even gonna tell what. I don't even know.
You. When I go on dates and a girl starts giving me that money vibes. I'm like,
do you, you can take a walk.
You, I know that Miami is a destination for vacation. You for the girls.
Just because they can go out there, go to club, not pay the entry,
not pay the code. Check, not pay nothing. Get in there.
Not even bring money. I've seen girls being a bouncer.
I've seen girls at clubs with nothing but $5 in.
And they come out of the club wasted.
But you wanna know why? Cause they know they don't need to. They,
they know that dudes came hungry and they know they got some olive garden pasta
on them. So somebody going eat, you feel me? And you know the thing is like me,
whenever I see this kind of behavior, I already got Jamie Fox cued in my phone.
you.
You.
You. They don't know that one. <laugh> they don't know that one. No, no, no.
That Kanye too. Okay. Oh.
Bye. Like the other two.
Better. And also like, you know, the bad lay. Like they, they listen.
They're probably only like that in the states out here.
They're certainly not like that. And when I was in Europe, they weren't like,
I mean, there's always gonna be some, there's always gonna be some,
but it's really, I don't know.
I think Instagram has just floated these ladies' ideas thinking just cuz they
look good. Every dude should throw the money. And that's why me personally,
if I found out a girl's done that in the past, I wouldn't even consider dating.
I, I, I look at you like your character's compromised by.
My yeah. That what you're saying? Like it's it's yeah, yeah, yeah.
Like tainted because you do you act like yeah, but you don't see,
you don't think them girls. No.
Yeah, yeah. It's not like they got a STD. It's like they got a TCD, you know,
what's that sexually transmitted character deficiency. You know what I'm saying?
Like, like, like, like they took some Dick and it took a piece of their,
of their, of their soul. You know what I'm saying?
It's the fact that it was transactional. Yeah.
I don't care if it's transactional.
It's not the transactional part that gives me it's the fact is the lack there of
like, I would respect more the transac that's IM I'm saying I would respect more
transaction. At least everybody getting something out of it.
There's some out there that are willing to be. Now I understand that.
That's not your thing. I'm not saying that. It's my thing.
I would say that I would respect you more. If it's transactional,
you're getting something outta it. They getting.
Something outta. Oh, I, I agree. But if you're not.
Even you're doing this to not even, that's a holdup.
Everyone got their thing. You know what I mean? If you trick,
but if you just out here looking cute on Instagram, talk about, you know,
send me money. Poppy and dudes will send you money and you fine with that.
I look at you different. That's just me personally. Now,
am I gonna go outta my way to call you names?
Of course I ain't got no time for that. But if you come at me afterwards,
talking about you are bugging, you are bugging. That's why like,
honestly I won't even front you bro. If I'm talking to a girl,
she got a high Instagram count in my head. I'm already like, oh word.
Of course not. Of course not funny.
Of course not. Maybe that's why I don't care.
It's not really my word. It doesn't mean that they're all like that.
But yo generally speaking, you know what I mean? I know when you get flown out.
Things that happen, you see things that's happening. Yeah. Yeah.
No. I was born out night. I wasn't born last night. You feel what I'm saying?
<laugh> remember that. Remember that? Yeah. Yeah. I'm not a Gor.
I know what goes on. I've seen those DMS. I've seen them.
Girls have shown me their inboxes. Yeah. Yeah. Down into.
DMA goes down.
One in particular had a couple milk and she was talking me was like, yep.
I got five, five digits to get
of course to a Sandy place. You.
Talk about Dubai, stop playing. We know, we know you talk about Dubai.
Dubai is a go-to place. We ain't talk about Las Vegas. We talk about Dubai,
Dubai, the new Las Vegas, where they get flown out. But.
Maybe she went there tomorrow. Shut.
The up. I've been working for the people that flyer at them out. Knock off.
Right? Hey, I said.
Come now, you know you, you know, I've been, I.
They play the game and this guy's playing the game. He's playing this character.
He's doing all this goofy on Instagram. It's all, it's all persona. It's all.
Maybe.
It's paying for him for whatever. He's trying to have a transaction, but oh.
Yeah. I mean everyone's, everyone's playing their part.
They're playing their role to get their money the same way their girl's like,
yeah. Poppy, whatever you want. Right. When want poppy, poppy,
they doing all that. Right? She's playing her role. She's getting her bag.
I and the same way he's doing what he's gotta do to get his,
but I could also look at it. I'm like, I don't respect it.
That's all it comes down to. Yeah, you could. You could. Yeah. Yeah, yeah. Yeah.
But when you rocking Gucci bags and you get flown out,
you probably don't care about a random respect.
If you can sleep with yourself at night, then go do what you,
you want do take her out shopping.
They got hundred bucks.
800. What are you talking about? Cause these girls got expensive tastes. They.
800 Bucks outta your pockets and go.
Is there any surprise that marriages are failing at the rate that they're
failing for better or for worse? No. No.
But think about it for better or for worse Popp, you got $800. Nah, man,
I'm struggling right now. Do like you understand.
Exactly what I was saying is because it's cause of what it's based on.
It's what it's based on. And that's not that it. Yeah. You know, and they're,
they're basing their whole relationship like that. He treats me good.
He pays for me, you know like a princess, just like how I like
getting you like a princess ain't to solve anything. You know? I mean,
it's not gonna raise kids, but whatever you do.
You, you know what kills me, mama,
you kills me is like a lot of these girls do this stuff. Right?
And they do the whole tricking thing where they, you know, paying for, for,
for lace and whatnot. Or even sometimes just
they get cash app. And then if you compare them to a sex worker,
they get so offended. You, you you're comparing me to them.
You're beneath them.
No. Cause they, they, they know the sex workers know exactly what they do.
That's what I'm saying.
I've always said it. I got no issue with girls who do that line of work.
I got no problem means the, the IG you just of cash at me. This is just.
Ugh. That's why I said, it's a holdup. You're still hero.
Cause like sex work is a transaction. Yes. People are happy to pay.
There's people that are happy to get paid. None of my business.
But now you just like, my.
Big problem is, is is paying for all of gotten pasta.
Like it's a three Michelin star restaurant and it's really men's fault.
My problem is that people actually base their actual,
if you're doing that for work and having for you, I don't care about that. Boo.
Boo, do you all day, every day. But if you date,
if you base your actual relate, your actual relationships on that,
you base relationships and you base how you're gonna date on that. Pay MEMA.
That's what have an issue.
If that's transactional for you and you just want people to actually not,
you don't wanna do anything and you wanna people pay, you know what?
I'm gonna take. What I, what I said back, do you still,
it's still a hold up a whole, hold up. You do you.
But if you're basing yourself on relationship on that and choosing your mate
on that, I'm.
Tell us what you guys think.
Hold
I.